images like this and nothing new China's
Navy flexing its muscle in the East and
South China Seas but regional tensions
have flared again recently over a number
of oil and gas-rich islands that have
been claimed in turn by China Vietnam
and the Philippines now some new images
have added fuel to the fire footage of
Vietnamese and Filipino troops in a
friendly football match on one of the
contentious Islands Philippine naval
officials said the event on the
Vietnamese held island shows there can
be harmony in the South China Sea
China's foreign ministry slammed the
sports games as a provocation we would
do though you know this little display
by Vietnam in the Philippines is just a
clumsy force china has irrefutable
sovereignty over the Spratly Islands and
the surrounding waters don't we demand
that the Philippines and Vietnam stop
any behavior that starts a dispute and
causes trouble Philippine call you an F
on yet China itself provoked an angry
backlash in the Philippines in Vietnam
last month when it installed an oil rig
in waters claimed by Hanoi several
people were killed in anti-chinese
protests
that violence has since subsided but the
war of words over territorial claims and
team sports in the South China Sea looks
set to continue